♪ ♪
>> Greg: NINE PROGRESSIVE
GROUPS HAVE JOINED TOGETHER TO
HELP STOP THE RIOTING THAT’S
DESTROYING OUR CITIES.
I LIVE.
THEY ARE PETITIONING TO TAPE
DELAY THE CONVENTION IN ORDER TO
FACT-CHECK THE SPEAKERS.
BECAUSE THOSE ARE ALL LIES.
CNN CALLED IT A PARADE OF LIES
AS THE LEADING FAKE NEWS NETWORK
I GUESS THEY WERE FRIGHTENED OF
THE COMPETITION.
SO HERE IS BIGGEST LIE.
>> WE HAD MULTIPLE SPEAKERS FROM
CONGRESSMAN STEVE SCALISE AND
JIM JORDAN TELL ECONOMIC RECORDS
THE DEFENDANT OBLITERATED BY THE
PANDEMIC.
THEY CITED THE LOWEST ON THE
PLANET RATE TO 50 YEARS.
WE DON’T HAVE THAT ANYMORE.
WE ARE A 10.2%, HIGHER THAN AT
ANY TIME SINCE THE GREAT
RECESSION.
>> Greg: REALLY?
REALLY?
FOR THAT TO BE A LAW YOU MUST BE
AN IDIOT OR YOU ASSUME AMERICA
CAN’T FACTOR THE SHUTDOWNS
EFFECTS ON THE NUMBERS BUT THEN
AGAIN IT IS CNN.
THOSE WERE AMAZING NUMBERS
BEFORE THE SHUTDOWN AND EVEN
TRUMP’S USUAL CRITICS KNOW THAT
DISPUTING THEM IS TOO STUPID A
PATH TO TAKE THE NOT THAT BOZO.
THE TRUMP ECONOMY WAS SO
POWERFUL IT IS STILL
WITHSTANDING A HURRICANE
DISGUISED AS THE DISEASE.
OTHER LIES FALL INTO THE USUAL
MUDDY AREA OF OPINION.
THERE’S ONE ABOUT TRUMP
DOWNPLAYING THE PANDEMIC.
THIS AFTER NOTING THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON JOBS FROM
THE SHUTDOWN THAT TRUMP
INITIATED.
THAT IS SOME DOWNPLAYING.
SHUTTING DOWN TRAVEL, THE
ECONOMY, GETTING VENTILATORS TO
THOSE WHO CLAIM WERE NEEDED AND
TRUMP DID THIS WITHOUT KILLING
PEOPLE IN REST HOMES.
MAYBE HE SHOULD WRITE A BOOK
ABOUT IT, INCLUDE PICTURE SO
ANDREW CUOMO CAN UNDERSTAND IT.
OF COURSE THEY IGNORE THE DEMS
AND EXPERTS WHO REALLY
DOWNPLAYED IT AND YOU CAN FIND
THOSE EASY.
>> OUR BIGGEST CONCERN TO YOU,
TO YOU AT HOME, IS INFLUENZA.
IT’S NOT CORONAVIRUS.
>> YOU ARE TELLING US IN THE
LAST HOUR THAT THERE IS AN
IMPORTANT CONTEXT WE NEED TO
KEEP IT IN AND THAT IS THAT THE
FLU IS MORE DEADLY.
>> YEAH.
>> HOW WORRIED SHOULD AMERICANS
BE ABOUT CORONAVIRUS?
>> CORONAVIRUS IS NOT GOING TO
CAUSE A MAJOR ISSUE.
>> HALF THE PEOPLE IN AMERICA
DON’T GET A FLU SHOT AND THE FLU
IS FAR DEADLY.
IF YOU ARE FREAKED OUT ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS YOU SHOULD BE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FLU.
>> Greg: WHO IS DOWNPLAYING?
HONEST MISTAKES BECAUSE THEY
WERE PREOCCUPIED.
I STILL WONDER HOW THIS PANDEMIC
WOULD LOOK IF THE GOVERNMENT
HADN’T BEEN HIJACKED BY PHONY
COLLUSION AND THE --
THEY BLAME TRUMP.
IT’S AMAZING WHEN THE
FACT-CHECKERS WAKE UP.
>> Katie: THE PERSON YOU HAD
ON AFTER THE DNC, THERE’S NOT
THAT MUCH TO DO.
NOT THAT MUCH FACT-CHECKING TO
DO.
FACT-CHECKERS ARE LIBERAL
REPORTERS WITH A DIFFERENT TITLE
TITLE.
THEY PRETEND THAT THEIR ARBITERS
OF THE TRUTH, THAT THEY ARE FAIR
AND LOOKING AT BOTH SIDES OF AN
ISSUE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THEY ARE
FACT-CHECKING, IT’S CLEAR THEY
ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN THE OTHER
93% OF REPORTERS THAT IDENTIFY
ON THE LEFT.
>> Greg: WHEN THEY FACT-CHECK,
THEY TEND TO PUT A SPIN ON IT.
REPUBLICANS SAID THAT THEY SENT
A PALLET OF CASH TO ARENDT, THE
FACT-CHECKERS IS NO THEY DIDN’T.
THEY SENT THE PALLETS OF CASH TO
IRAN BUT IT WAS MEANT FOR
SOMETHING ELSE.
IT’S LIKE YOU, WE WILL TAKE THE
FIRST PART OF THE SENTENCE,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Jesse: IT’S LIKE THE DNC
RAPID RESPONSE.
I PREDICT THAT THE FACT-CHECKER
IS PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE A JOB
IN A DEMOCRATIC POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN BECAUSE CNN PROBABLY
ISN’T PAYING HIM THAT WELL.
I LOVE, TO DANA’S POINT EARLIER,
YOU HAVE THE REPUBLICANS AND
THEY SAY MARAUDING MOBS OF
SOCIALISTS ARE GOING TO DESTROY
YOUR FAMILY AND YOUR BUSINESS
THEN YOU HAVE THE DNC SAYING
DONALD TRUMP WILL DESTROY
DEMOCRACY, PILE OF BLACK BODIES
AND GIVE YOU COVID-19.
AND THE MEDIA SAYS DEMOCRATS ARE
UPLIFTING AND UNIFYING AND THE
REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE SAYING THE EXACT SAME
THING AND THE FACT THAT I,
JESSE WATTERS, HAS THE
INTELLECTUAL HONESTY TO SAY THAT
BOTH PARTIES PAINT DIRE PICTURES
OF THE OTHER PARTY IF THEY ARE
IN CHARGE AND CNN DOESN’T TELLS
YOU A LOT.
>> Greg: JUAN, DO YOU AGREE
WITH JESSE, THAT HE’S BEING
HONEST?
>> Juan: NO.
YOU KNOW IT STRIKES ME IS FACTS
ARE STUBBORN THINGS, THEY ARE
REAL.
>> Greg: DID YOU INVENT THAT?
>> Juan: YOU HEAR THE TRUMP
PEOPLE SAY HE’S DONE A GREAT JOB
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS.
DID THEY MISS 170,000 AMERICANS?
>> Greg: HE KILLED THOSE
PEOPLE.
HE KILLED THOSE PEOPLE.
HOW DARE HE?
>> Juan: IT’S A FACT.
>> Greg: WE EXPECTED MILLIONS.
>> Juan: TRUMP PROMISED 4% GDP
GROWTH, NEVER ACHIEVED UNDER
TRUMP, NEVER.
THAT’S A FACT TO LIVE WITH.
YOU POINT OUT FAILURES LIKE
THAT, IT’S VERY HARD, AND
SOMEHOW YOU WANT TO EXCUSE IT AS
WAS THE DIFFERENCE.
FACTS ARE FACTS.
>> Greg: I MISSED YOUR FACTS.
DANA.
>> Dana: I THINK LAST WEEK THE
FACT-CHECKERS GOT THE WEEK OFF
BUT THAT WAS OKAY BECAUSE YOU
CAN’T FACT-CHECK EMOTIONS.
THERE WAS ONE THING LAST WEEK,
THE AP DID FACT-CHECK
MICHELLE OBAMA SPEECH WHEN SHE
TALKED ABOUT PUTTING KIDS IN
CAGES AND THEY SAID HOLD ON A
SECOND.
THAT WHOLE POLICY, THE CAGES
WERE BUILT, THAT WAS UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
I DID THINK THAT ONE
FACT-CHECKED.
THEY FACT-CHECK NIKKI HALEY FOR
CALLING BIDEN’S OPTION
GOVERNMENT RUN HEALTH CARE.
IF YOU REMEMBER WHEN OBAMACARE
WAS BEING PASSED, DEMOCRATS
OPENLY CAMPAIGNED ON THIS BEING
THE STEP TO GET TO MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
I DON’T THINK THAT FACT-CHECK
NEEDED TO BE DONE.
>> Greg: ALSO WHEN THEY SAID
IF WE DID NOTHING AGAINST THE
CORONAVIRUS WE COULD SEE BETWEEN
1.5 AND 2 MILLION DEATHS AND